thank you thank you thank you thank you
come on I know this is all for what's
next so as I'm sure you're all aware the
marble panel is coming up
how many outta curiosity how many of you
been here all day
how many of you have been waiting for
the marble pit so let's not make you
wait much longer one last one last time
remember the footage don't record it we
want to make sure they feel comfortable
bringing it so just do us a favor don't
recording photographer you saw it first
but don't record it so at this time it
is my pleasure to introduce the
moderator for marble mr. Chris Hardwick
welcome polish I am a marginally
passable booker dewitt AKA chris
hardwick here for the Marvel panel which
I can't even begin to tell you the
things you guys are going to see in the
next hour
if you've wait have you been awaited all
day how many people played in your all
day oh Jesus you move my queue there it
is going to be entirely where that I am
so just as a fan of stuff you've no idea
how exciting is for me to be able to
show you the things you're going to see
so I'm going to get this kicked off
right now I would like to present to the
stage the president of Marvel Studios a
producer of Iron Man Thor Captain
America the Avengers mr. Kevin Feige
no no he's like Kevin hello Annika hello
you are the last row of unknown puppetry
my friends this has been an incredible
year for you congratulations on Iron Man
3 thank you very much thank you it
always starts right here it's a good
lights our good luck charm it is well
they sort of talk because you come here
and you say you present something
they're like oh crap we're gonna go make
that you know yes so guess finish it so
what's coming up next
well meet a lot of things coming up next
certainly many which I hope are worth
waiting in line all night for I hope so
I think so so I think they are or in
post-production a movie called for the
dark world right now
lining up in the sweltering heat for
hours
Holling forget her in the dark like
these
alas God and I am burdened with glorious
service stand back you mewling quim the
bright lure of freedom diminishes your
life's joy in a mad scramble for a place
in this chain in this meager palace of
video the arena they call Hall the page
you should have let me Rudy when you had
the chance
yeah here you are
near your ears
yeah for untold stories your eyes crave
unseen sights your imaginations ate and
hunger
where are your Avengers now
claim loyalty to me and I will give you
what you need
say my name say my name
it seems I have pleased your eyes ladies
and gentlemen no filming or recording of
any nature at this time please put on
your 3d glasses
so Kevin things are good
congratulations the footage looks
amazing so we comes ended November
November 8th so just sort of turning our
attention where we have with the next
one well the next one is the in Captain
America as we reveal as we reveal last
year this hall the name the movie is
Captain America the Winter Soldier we
have not finished building yet we we
have one more week to go ok but some
people came by a lot to say hi did you
spring them in you want to bring them
the directors of Captain America the
Winter Soldier Joe Anthony Russo we're
going to bring them all out as Brock
rumlow Frank Grillo
as age of 13 aka Chad Carter
Emily VanCamp you remember agent Murray
he'll come smaller
introducing for the first time anywhere
onstage for Marvel
Sam Wilson aka the Falcon Anthony Mackie
you he used to go by the name Bucky
Barnes he now is go by the name the
Winter Soldier Sebastian Stan he's he's
the adventures boss he's really all of
our bosses Samuel Jackson
natasha romanoff Scarlett Johansson and
the super-soldier see branches Captain
America
hey welcome you guys welcome to Comic
Con 2013 Captain America Chris we'll
start it start with you you've done this
few times now you've been in the cap
suit a few times now how does it feel
each time you go back and put it on
there's a piece of you now
well it's getting better every time I
put it back on you know it's it's
satisfying knowing that the movies are
good you know it really be a problem if
the franchise you were stuck with I
wasn't making good products but it turns
out Marvel knows what they're doing so
every time you put this yeah
preserves that series I think put the
suit back on you get really excited and
you can't wait to see what they're gonna
do
how does it I think ski fields think
he's a just to get disturb anachronistic
you know is he feeling comfortable yet
in our world Molly's getting there I
mean he's not it's not so much about his
shock with technically not illegal
internet you know I mean it's more about
it's more about the societal differences
with the 40s to today I think he comes
from a world where people are a little
more trusting and I think the threats
weren't as deep and you know the world
we live in right now it's harder to know
what's right and wrong and what's good
and bad in the 40s I think we can all
agree
Nazis are bad it's pretty clear there's
still bad by the way that's black and
white but today it's harder to know
who's right who's wrong and sometimes
the actions you have to take to prevent
certain threats compromise some of our
civil degrees or our privacy and I think
that's tough for Steve to swallow
scarlet cytosine etosha how integral to
the story is she and how much you know
how much a part of my soldiers Edition
very like yes I mean she she and Chris
shared this movement maybe when I think
that you know obviously when we find
these characters they it's in real-time
so we've been working together for a
couple of years and um you know they
have this shorthand between them they're
really kind of partners even they do
their running on their cast together
they know on a mission CMO and stuff so
um they these two characters we didn't
really see a lot of interaction between
them in Avengers now have this
relationship that they've built you know
which i think is an opportunity for us
to kind of see a little bit morning I
don't want to say the civilian side of
Natasha but we get to see how she is a
more kind of casual working relationship
with somebody and see that it's kind of
breaks down the barriers of her of her
kind of pasquale that she's put up a
little bit and you learn
we should say there's more fighting
about the same fighting for her ventures
to this movie um
this film is gritty it's got a lot of
kind of down dirty huckleberry
Huckleberry fighting all that stuff so
we're really uh there's a lot of action
this one I mean character was she's she
knows in the world she's she's a child
of this world that she's in what if
there is a relationship to Steve I think
that you know they have a sort of
unexpected sort of unexpectedly simple
not somebody I'd say it's like an odd
couple you know I think we each have
pretty different approaches to morality
and I think that makes for an
interesting that God made this really in
this movie in this relationship because
they need one they learn from each other
as well you know economies are sexy they
learn from another whoo education
let's talk to Sam for a second CIN
Jackson Nick Fury as I feel every time
the eyepatch goes on and then you're
Nick Fury mode
how does he view how does he view all of
these people deceive you that I said
children or co-workers does he feel
responsible for them their chemical
workers subordinates have a sense of
instruments of justice in no way tools
but people that he cares about he has a
different relationship with everybody he
and Steve have a way of talking because
they're both boys
he knows the world he came from the
facility because he was soldiering
around their time so they could talk in
that way but he also knows that he has
his black and white think about who's
the enemy who the good guys he's in a
world now where some of those enemies or
people that he received his enemies may
now be our comrades and you don't know
how that happened about how that works
but you know that's the gray area that
sort of shield and people in the shadow
world like Natasha not working and
almost everything comes out of a series
sometimes he had to figure out you know
am i lying to myself too so there's
always that but pretty cool do you think
you really because I always feel like oh
yeah he always knows what's going on do
you feel like he always was a good at
faking video because going
um he has a very good idea of what's
going on but his paranoia keeps them
from believing what's going on if that's
really you know that way or this way so
he having goals around the corner to see
what's really happening yeah Sebastian
for a second questions so it's also good
about what's going on with this idea of
the Winter Soldier and Bucky how are you
feeling and how did you fit in I felt
great I said you know I was I was very
happy and I found out that story was
going to come to life on screen and I
mean you know story yeah we know I
actually how close is this sticking to
the bigger part of ultra soldier and
where did it it's pretty close it's
pretty close to the specifics as they
relate to is they relate to Bucky
okay for sure yeah and it's you look
many people is rooms right the story
it's not a twist who he was I introduced
with both maids in the movie though is a
surprise to Kat and that's what matters
me that is needs cats monthly and it
took you know you don't become in they
go together even better but it's really
the surprise is for cat great uh Anthony
thank you sorry I was in New Orleans
it is welcome tell us about the Falcon
tell us tell us what's going on in which
is over oh well I'm introducing the
Falcon Sam Wilson I have wings and guns
right that's all you need right when you
go to grocery store don't want wings it
go that's what I got
so you know we cap the while we give him
the business give him the business
give us some business help it doesn't
give him the business we just hand in
our business but to our s go free to
Captain America to every album coming
out of Excel Kevin with the with the
Russos what was it about the Russos that
made you say like these are the guys to
tell the story of the Winter Soldier you
know and Marvel we've always been
rewarded when we hire people who have
done really clever interesting things
they don't have to be the exact same
things we can hire this cute but these
guys have been part shows called the
rest of development community and I kept
seeing the Navy pop up again again and
we you want to hear me talk about you
want to show me why I hire them sure you
let's show you why we hired them we ever
best movie of the year - does it take a
few seconds for them to transition over
Captain America Winter Soldier this is
for the Russos I saw Robert Redford how
how yeah what how did you have a good
movie but he's fantastic n it was
amazing because you know the movie is
really based on art
tom is derived from seventies political
thrillers and he started so many great
ones if they're really having the film
really makes it feel like it's come full
circle yeah and so how are you guys
bringing this story this is on such a
huge scale from other stuff that you've
done what was the task daunting or
exciting or how did it feel respond I
mean we keep stuff we keep saying is the
best job we've ever had I mean I started
collecting comic books when I was 10 so
to be able to come and present this
footage at college is like it's a dream
come true so just really quickly I
wanted to hear from the last couple of
panels down
Koby welcome back where's Maria Hill in
this story I'm sorry where is Maria and
the story well you know shielded is
picking out where we left off after the
Avengers after the Battle of New York
and the world is still sort of really
from the reveal of superheroes and
aliens and so shields try to find its
place within this new world and hails
working with fury again and we're trying
to keep everybody in check there's some
there's some few people coming on board
and and Maria's part is to sort of I
can't reveal too much it's very hard to
talk on these handles but it's basically
trying to find our way in this in this
game world where we find ourselves
so speaking of new Emily with eighteen
thirteen tell us you know kind of feel
coming into this sort of pre this sort
of pre-existing structure of people who
would work together and story what's a
bit like for you oh it's been awesome I
mean I would be lying if I said it
wasn't a little bit intimidating you
know but um he an awesome experience as
a great character in play and really
we're just sort of introducing his
characters so yeah can't fit your
village same for young Frank Brock Brock
rumlow yeah uh Angie Maggie Mae
reference to how he was kidding
he was my just saw captain I was a
little bit so it we can't say much but
it is
continue I'm sorry
tick yeah could take you Playboy it's a
lot of fun okay excellent for you guys
thank you all so much for being here
today the footage she brought was
amazing to come on to the fans and say
hi everyone
a huge round of applause for Captain
America which is over thank you so much
for coming
and they'll be massive opportunities
over there the corner
there they go
Captain America click click click click
I'm man photobombing again
Oh again
alright so haven't even claimed a lot of
properties that you've been dealing with
for a long time you know you're in
second movies going into other ones like
what is there anything you you have
anything new for people people like new
things do you like new things well you
know we we try to plan years and years
out you know that we were here at
comic-con 2006 talking about one day
making the Avengers and and we have been
planning at that entire time and a lot
of what we think about is how many of
these movies are we going to be able to
make how long can we keep them
interested and the answer always is as
long as they're new and they're fresh
and we pull from great source material
hopefully we'll be interesting but we
want something new it's something
unexpected not just something familiar
and that's what led us last year to
announce guardians of the galaxy now now
we we've literally just started building
guardians of the galaxy in London we are
on day I think yesterday was day 13 or
14 so it's very very early days we very
much wanted to come here and say hi so
they decided to come here
as yondu michael rooker
playing nebula karen gillan
as Korath John and Hobson
a newcomer to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Ronan the accuser
Lee pace
as the collector Benicio del Toro
you guys want me Drax the destroyer
different Esau playing the biggest woman
in the galaxy Gamora Zoe Saldana and as
the next great Marvel hero star-lord
Chris Pratt
we're a family
brevet organizing what you're wearing
this on acceptor you stay down there
kids good oh wow sure kill it hooker
but everyone years of behind the scenes
of what just happened right now first of
all Vinicio comfy smelling my pits
because I'm kind of thinking you lose
escaping on a plane made fun of me uncle
smelly true and then I was easy and I
shared the fact that we both at big leak
really bad let's go before the panel Co
come out of there I think we've in fact
are a long time this is amazing what you
guys would understand that they
literally just flew in for this and are
leaving again tonight to go back to
London
so James I'll start with you because I
know you and we have you first got this
job that you were like I'm excited but
I'm kind of freaked out I mean you know
coming up movies like super or
something's like more intimate how do
you you know like what is the story that
you're telling him how are you attacking
it you know exactly the same you know
it's kind of knows I really like the
plane everything out I like to know
exactly what we're doing it's always
been important to be that I've worked
with the cast and crew of people who I
not only respect their talent but I
really like those people and I think we
want to easily completely unique with
guardians and I've been able to do that
with these folks here and it's just been
amazing experience and in a way it is no
different than you know when you need
independent film Marvel's be great in
all their films of doing something new
and different and we're trying to design
knowing different yeah Chris I fear the
recent photos of you sort of blow up
reddit whereas just went to this amazing
body transform
and was that to get ready for this for
this movie
no nothing to do it was just weird
timing new movie yeah I got the role
like six months ago and they were like
great job but you're too fast all right
I can work on that so lovely they
trusted me and then and then got me a
personal trainer so so who is our Lord
Allah who who is this guy that works uh
you know I can't tell you a lot I can't
tell you is that I play a FedEx
executive who goes down am I crash
absolutely on an island I think that's
kind of it oh never to a motive all
right let's have yeah my butt used to
equalise the volleyball star peak will
and starboard is like this guy who loses
space you know he's like oh I don't know
exactly I didn't say but he's just here
he's kind of a jerk like had had a hard
time as a kid and now
around space making out with hot alien
girls and and kind of just being a rogue
in a bit of a jerk command you know
through team help with these guys finds
a higher purpose for himself which is to
let you know like really care about
something really divided and put his
life on the line to help this new family
that you find so so that's Google as
fool's Zoe
how were you playing Gamora within the
universe I it's exciting it's an I've
been blue ones so I thought why not try
green and now and I'm having a great
time like I said I love being in space I
love being challenged by great great
roles that especially a company like
Marvel creates amazing amazing movies
that given only the audience an
adventure but also give us as artists
give us an opportunity to sort of be
challenged and be able to embody amazing
multi-layered character so like my
nephew my 11 year old nephew said he was
like what do you think amaura is who you
think she is I'm like well you know
she's a feisty warriors your ha ha she's
an assassin
so I
Dave what do you what do you think
you're bringing two drags besides your
generous physical structure I'm still at
the point where I go to set everyday I
still just can't frickin believe I got
this job I don't know you know I changed
saw something in me when I auditioned I
did yeah I'm still not sure we do see I
ask myself Dave earn this job you
audition six SMI five i market based on
his acting ability which is tremendous a
lot of my fought really hard for mister
and he's gonna freak people out really
truly yes I did I fought really hard for
this job and I have to admit something
that I wanted more anything I've ever
wanted in my life and when I got Java
broke down so I can now this is still
I'm still you know I'm you know I'm 44
years old but I'm still the baby on the
set in terms of I can experience so I go
to work every day and just try to learn
something new try to stretch my range of
emotions and really just you James what
you want to also just play off the other
actors who are so talented
I'm so lucky to have them because I need
at this point I can't just I need
something work with I need cops I need
people
something I can't just pull it out I
still have that experience you just pull
it out of nowhere so I'm very much to
have such great director and such that
pretty cool stuff it's a sweet so I've
been lucky but I'm fragile and weak but
easy how did how did you get involved
how did you get involved with the movies
you know James before did he reach out
to you what was yours what was your
approach a phone call James called me
and asked me if I would read this story
in a written great story and I can't
talk too much about enter but it was a
very cool Mike I'm new one here I
haven't I didn't come from London I came
from Los Angeles I have to start at the
movie yet so something yeah go Dodger so
so so I just I just I'm leading the
whole cast for the first time just like
everyone's so oh well that's Dave and it
leaves next to you
so Chris was very cool thank you for
coming down to them to the panel thank
you hey who is Ronan the accuser he's a
very complicated freak
he's uh he's a beast it's uh he's an
iconic character from Marvel since 1967
and I don't want to say too much right
now because um we're gonna put it on the
screen
come on Simon have you starting have you
started working at or is this if your
teachers from them the panel as well oh
no I came down from the panel but uh
I've already started and or more
importantly I wanted Jesus told me how
big it was and and when I met him I
suddenly understood he told me that at
dinner one night knows the most
operations like right now
so but I'm playing Cora and choruses is
a humanoid a great I lied to a grave I
like I like to roll in and I'm Karen I
know so it was so hard was hard for
life's a divide anything moment but I
think I just old many of us were
thrilled but it was like you immediately
started working a month let's say
immediately started working and your mom
with this movie I know people were
really excited about my my question
though is that this is nebula fault yeah
something a little bit crazy
she means that man oh please heard you
got the parrot man put away your
mechanical pencils you do not want to
give your wings if he for the jump I
don't want to know what's going to
happen yes
you look amazing
yeah definitely I was a little worried
that was going to look like an overgrown
fetus it's liberating
it's really diverging I think everyone
here should change their head do it hey
we just pulled you out of the matrix
spaces yeah well
finally my Kroger there's no salary
like first of all where's mom like you
gotta let her go but it's nice to see
you back how have you started filming
already you actually you came back from
London you
hyejeong people that marilla's gone he
died two times in one episode Gannon
Glen God let it go
I like your hand yeah so one murderer
nothing I just love seem to you guys
yeah my hair is very soft president
well those you guys I think you're
actually grande I know you guys just
started but I also know that you maybe
have prepared something for folks here
remember only ten days of filming they
just starting brought it with them let's
take a look right now to go to easily
London
like a green you
there they go
oh no really yeah that's pretty much it
you guys this is a very exciting panel
we saw a lot of amazing stuff thanks so
much see you guys later
you guys I know the Cap'n Swift panel is
up next
did you forget something
look there's only one more person here
he wanted to come say hi
certain okay
hi I know it's time to go I don't really
have anything to say but I have one
thing to add if we could please